because you saw the bat that morning
show where he was interview where he was
being interviewed about the stuff right
and the whole interview was basically
about how famous he is now right right
you know he's just stickers and he's
like I have a sticker everybody has a
sticker it's like a sticker my dog has a
sticker saying what the [ __ ] wrote like
relax man like you could now it makes
that ID live a lot more believable that
he was kind of in it just for the fame
right right because you didn't really
treat her respectfully and mind you like
the stuff that you see on the show is
[ __ ] hilarious like earlier I did a
reference about the eat the mouse I
guess the the dad asked II D to take a
shower to get us that they do cuz after
a night of like the torrential downpour
of rain and like the bed being flooded
the neck didn't go sleep and she's
making fun of him for that and it makes
me think about like Danone narrative
goes back and forth because he said he
set his like special sheets mm-hmm
to that to the Philippines so that it
would like pees or his skin conditioner
yeah what if he has but they never
arrived
it makes me think like maybe they just
sold that [ __ ] yeah so that's the
narrative I was rolling with now I'm
like neither you telling me this I don't
know what to think who knows because he
was saying that he was sending but he
sent like five thousand dollars worth
the gifts to her yeah and none of that
[ __ ] arrived but then it's five hours
away from Manila yeah yeah who [ __ ]
know they had to take this shower and
it's the funniest [ __ ] scene because
I don't think he realized like first of
all like the Philippines the rural area
is pretty pretty bad right here in world
man and I've never been to the
Philippines but I'm saying this from
Filipino friends who told me about the
rule areas the Philippines like it's
still really bad up and when you don't
have like people live really rich or
they live really poor right just how a
lot of these Asian countries and so he's
taking a shower this book first of all
how he's reacting they take a shower and
they go he goes are those chickens like
a chicken coop right over here I think
instead that you get shower there's this
[ __ ] mangy little rat and it's like
Master Splinter
if I even move in it's like yeah it's so
old it's like the oldest rat ever
chilling on his slippers yeah right and
he goes is that a rat and she goes I eat
the mouse the mouse I think it's a mouse
she was like it's a rat I'd maybe she
starts clowning on him cuz she's like oh
what that baby yeah baby yeah cuz her
reality of what she lives in is just her
every day and then what he expected was
something completely different
hmm it was kind of crazy when I saw that
[ __ ] but her living conditions her
living edition right because it also
like see cuz I've never seen it now it's
the first time I've seen like these
really harsh conditions and it makes me
think about like my best friend Mark who
it they had like this Exodus were like
10 of his relatives like flew over they
put him up in his home in complex in our
apartment complex is a 2-bedroom with
like 10 people damn
so people two people were sleeping in
the tub people sleeping on the bottom of
the the kitchen people are like a bunch
of people in both bedrooms I'm like man
this is crazy
and every time they would ask me like
can we borrow your weight scale and yeah
yeah is that's like a common things you
have to wait that thing and my sin
altars [ __ ] back to the Philippines on
my manases you know when we go to like
even when we my mom used to gift basic
stuff to like people in Korea and
because USA made stuff is more regulated
than it is like in Asia in China so for
example they would ask us to send them
like centrum from Costco yeah [ __ ]
centrum things like [ __ ] yeah it's weird
I didn't buy scene I was like this made
why yeah it was like like basic [ __ ]
like said some Pedialyte all this other
random video and it was because they
don't trust like the stuff that they get
from China they said like the stuff from
China or whatever is made in Asia is
regulated and it's pretty bad and they
want American brand stuff so my mom was
said like [ __ ]
Flintstone vitamins and [ __ ] like what
they don't want this [ __ ] yeah my mom's
I know this is the stuff that they want
so they would have to package like
suitcases full of stuff in Korea we had
to fill that [ __ ] up and bring it over
yeah he would come over like every other
week say don't daddy bleep can I use
your weights girl I'm a dab you like no
you can't use
you had your Herbert no you can't my mom
was like Oh take it take it just call
ahead I know the situation yeah so funny
man I mean we're like what the [ __ ]
what's it called when they were he
didn't last in that area for too long
because remember he also has a skin
condition where he's in some kind of
dermatitis yeah and then Oh [ __ ] he
had to sleep on the floor with his
clothes and there was a scene the way
that the Edit the show is [ __ ] funny
like that he goes my bats grind yes I
mean it was a moment and he slept with
his head on the wall
well and then they went to the pig farm
the piggy farm the pig farm would you
fire me because just dropping the
football oh [ __ ] I'm so sorry expect
when you put plastic bags on your shoes
bro like just wrap it up and wrap it up
and let it go yeah yeah yeah you buy
some new shoes
I didn't the [ __ ] crazy thing was the
dead sleeps right next to the [ __ ]
pig yeah dude with the with the cargo
slash it just sleeps right next to him
yeah this [ __ ] insane have you as
funny have you seen any other of the
other episodes with I mean I'm caught up
bro
I mean I guess the next episode comes
out tomorrow did you see in this season
who do they have they have big ed they
have bad Big Ed I don't know their names
they had loose man loose mind Lisa may
be a girl baby love baby love she's
[ __ ] mean dude she's really mean
she's [ __ ] mean to that yeah yeah the
amount of disrespect she has towards him
is unfuckin so funny because she treats
him like the sir typical assumption you
would have about a Nigerian yeah